welcome to web scraping with
python my name is richard kirschner with
the simply learn team
that's www.simplylearn.com get certified
get ahead certainly there are many
reasons to be able to go
online and scrape different websites
they range everything
from pulling out different links to
pulling data off of websites as a data
scientist you might need to get some
information off a website that doesn't
have a direct api to pull that
information
and in python we have a wonderful tool
when you talk python and you talk web
scraping we're talking
beautiful suit which is a package you
add into your python that you're running
and we can come over here to the website
www.crummy.com
software slash beautiful soup you can
actually read a little bit about it
currently beautiful soup 4 is the
current version
if you don't remember the full website
for it you can always do what i do which
is go over and do a search for beautiful
soup
official site it almost always comes up
right at the top and you click on there
and it'll take you to the crummy.com
software
site for beautiful soup now we're going
to use our whatever python
interface you want ide i'm going to use
jupiter lab
which is built on jupiter notebook
through anaconda
jupiter lab is jupiter notebook with
added tabs and some added features
it's basically in beta testing so it's
got a few little glitches when you're
saving things and moving between
projects but for the most part it's a
great upgrade to the jupiter notebook
and you can use them together so you
don't have to i mean it's built on
jupyter notebooks anything you do in
jupyter notebook you can open up in
jupiter lab
and the first thing we need to do is we
need to go ahead in this case i'm going
under my environments since it
partitions the environments out
and i'm going to open up a terminal
window we have to install some packages
in here to work with
now there's a lot of choices on this i
because of the simplicity we'll be using
conda install now you can use pip
install for the same thing and we're
going to install our beautiful soup
4. you have to type out the whole thing
beautiful soup four and you can use a
pip install if you're using a different
environment
and i am using python version 3.6
although according to beautiful soup
they also work on three seven all the
way from two seven
through all of 3x now according to the
beautiful soup website the beautiful
soup 4 works on
anything you can install on anything
from python 2 7 all the way through any
of the python 3 versions
this just happens to be python 36
because they do there's a lot of other
packages that don't work on
three seven yet and we'll go ahead and
run this install on here and let it go
through its environmental
setup and of course with conda it goes
in there and finds all the dependencies
pip doesn't do as much as far as finding
dependencies but you know exactly what's
on there with
pip so if you're doing a huge
distribution you probably want to use
your
pip install so you can track what's
going on there with the
conda i like to just let it take over
since this isn't a major distributed
package going out another quick note
between pip and conda
is that if you start on a project in one
of these environments and you're using
pip in there stick with pip if you're
using conda stick with conda they track
the packages and you can run into some
issues where they're not tracking the
same packages and something gets
overwritten so it's important to stay
very consistent with your install on
your environments
and we'll also need to go ahead and
install our
numpy environment and our pandas on here
so go ahead and do that if you haven't
added those packages in
go ahead and install those into your
environment that you're working in
and of course pandas is just simply
install pandas
and let's just install a couple more
packages in this case let's get our
install our map plot library because
we're going to plot at the end since
we're going to be collecting data
and for this project that will be all
the packages we'll need so we can go and
close out of our installer or whatever
setup you have
and we'll go back to home and we'll just
launch our jupiter lab and that will
open up in our browser window now
if you're coming from jupiter notebooks
and first time in lab
we can go ahead and just create our
first notebook python 3.
you can also do it under file launcher
and you'll see new notebook
it automatically opens up and we just
click right on there it'll pop open on
the left
and i'll right click this and we'll
rename this we'll rename it uh just
beautiful and it is
a i pi nb file on there so that should
look familiar because that's the jupyter
notebook file this is a new one now
i have more tabs in the past i usually
hid this on the other computer all my
notes for the
lesson today but this is my notes going
down and we'll go ahead and just start
going through this
and see what it looks like to do a data
poll from front to
end and see how that works as a data
scientist pulling that information in
from the website
and the first thing i want to do is i
want to go ahead and close this side
window that way it looks get the nice
full screen and we can also up the size
a little bit
one of the wonderful things about
working in a browser window just do that
control plus thing
the packages we talked about is pandas
so we imported our pandas if you haven't
already that's our data frame
if you haven't done our pandas tutorial
definitely worthy of
the time to go through there and
understand pandas because it's such a
powerful tool
this basically turns your data into a
spreadsheet data frame
our numpy is our number array so it kind
of works with pandas very closely as far
as manipulating data in arrays
map plot we want to go ahead and bring
that in our plt so that we can plot the
data at the end
and this line right here that says
matplot library inline
is for the jupyter notebook specifically
it tells it to print that on this page
a lot of the newer versions don't
actually require to have that line
they'll still print it on the page but
you should still include that if you're
in the jupyter lab
setup and then we have our url library
dot request we're going to import url
open for opening up the website and then
we have
our bs4 that's your beautiful soup four
we're going to import
beautiful soup and then our last one is
our
re that is for manipulating our regular
expressions
so we get to that part of importing our
data we have to do a lot of reformatting
so it's something we can use
and the re is one of those tools we'll
go ahead and run this
and just bring all that in so this is
all imported all these packages are now
into our web scraping program we're
going to run now if we're going to dive
in and pull data we should have a nice
website to pull from
and let's go ahead and we'll use the
upper timing.com results for the 2018
martin luther king race and if we take
this you can actually just take this
where did we get this from well you can
go in here and find the website you're
going to scrape from
and you'll see right here it says you
just copy that link right in there that
http
and this is the website that we're
looking at you can see right here all
the information
that we're looking at let's say we
wanted to run some statistics on this
it sure would be nice to be able to pull
it off of here and if they don't have a
direct api that means we need to pull it
from their website
some of these will have a download
although if you've ever done a we have a
download click
and maybe you're paging through a
hundred websites uh in one case
i was uh polling all the different
united states
bills that are passed to track who voted
on them for a project
and you can imagine that there's you
know hundreds and hundreds of those
thousands of these documents that they
voted on who voted on it goes through
the senate goes back to the congress
so i opened up a website pull all the
links off of there
that match a certain criteria and we'll
look at that in just a minute how we go
through the html
and then i had to reformat them or i
could hand download each one one at a
time which would just be a nightmare so
it's nice to automate it in this case
we're going to be pulling up this chart
we want to figure out how to pull this
chart off of this website
and so we go back into our jupiter
notebook i've got my url just
um our name for it and it's just a
string that's all this is
nothing fancy there you'll notice that
on the slashes we now have forward
forward slash
you can do a single forward and http is
a double forward this is just
how you have to switch it to match setup
in there and then it's going to go ahead
and use the html equals url
open url and that's from our url library
request
so it's opening a link to that website
or at least pointing to it
and if we run this this just sets it up
so this is all set up and then once
we've done our
setup let's go ahead and create an
object called soup this will be
and if you remember up here here's our
beautiful soup that we imported
from the bs4 and this is the package
that we're working with
and so we're going to do our beautiful
soup on here and on this we need to go
ahead and send it
our html so it knows what it's opening
and then the second part
is we have to tell it how the format is
coming in and the most common one for
your html polls is an lxml
setup and so almost all of them you'll
end up using the lxml there's a few
other options
and because this is so common uh in the
newer versions
a lot of times they just leave it out
just because it's already on the default
we'll go ahead and leave it in here just
to remind us that it's there we'll go
ahead and run that
and on the newer versions uh they
actually default it to the xml setup in
the html we'll just leave it out and
call it html so it's just going to pull
from this
url and when we run that on here we've
now created an object soup
that has pulled the website into it so
soup contains the information
along with information on that website
and what's going on
so let's just go over what we did real
quick before we start digging into
the actual soup before we start scooping
out stuff we imported
our different modules that we're going
to use with our package
specifically the beautiful soup we did
install the beautiful soup if you
remember correctly you have to call it
beautiful soup
4 specifically so it knows what you're
bringing in and this line right here is
very
key from bs4 because that's how it
installs the module
we're importing our beautiful soup and
then we found our url
in this case we're going to go pull
information from the martin luther king
dream run
and then we set our html to our url open
url
and you can see right here we imported
that so here's our url.request
import url open so we're requesting a
connection and once we send that
connection into the beautiful soup it
creates an object called
soup and then this one of course we
chose soup just because it goes with
beautiful soup i guess we could have
chosen beautiful
and now we can start extracting
information from
our website because we pulled it down
onto our computer
under soup now we can start by looking
at the title of the website
soup.title and if we print title
dot text you'll see this a lot in
beautiful suit because
title contains all kinds of information
and if we want just the text from that
title you add the dot text on the end
and you can see right here we have our
2018 mlk
dream run 5k race results if you look at
the tab that's the actual title up here
uh 2018 mlk dream run 5k
race that's what the title is on the
website and then you might be curious
what's in title what's the whole title
that it's storing up there well let's go
ahead and print it out here's print
title and print title.txt and we run
that you can see
it has the html tags title on it and
then the
forward slash title to end it and so
we're really just pulling off
this piece of the html code and then we
look at the text
inside that particular part of the html
and earlier i mentioned links what if
you want to get all the links off this
page
well that would be fun uh we could do
soup dot and we'll do
find underscore all put this in bracket
and then quotation marks we're going to
put a a is the
key find and you'll start seeing a div
and all the different options you have
for finding these entities in a website
and then let's go ahead and just print
our links
and you can see here that it now shows
all the different links in here that are
marked by
eggs we did a find all a and then we can
also because this is a little bit hard
to pull off the h
reference so we can also add in our find
all
fine-tune that in this case the h
reference equals true we'll actually
filter that out
and then finally we might do a four
link in links and we can simply do
something like this for each link
we want to actually find the h reference
because we know there's an h reference
in it
and if i run this you can see it just
comes through and prints them out one at
a time some of these are really useful
so you might be looking for
something that has https in it and you
know that's a link running to something
else
or you might be looking for the mail to
tags you know that's all the mail
addresses but either way you can easily
find all the links in your
html document that you're paging through
and of course
any packages that have evolved over time
you can also do
link dot get h reference which should do
the same thing as our other format
and you can see it certainly does we get
the same printout up here
in this particular case we really want
to get the data off the page
uh so let's go ahead and do that let's
see what that looks like
and in data let's call it all rows there
we go equals and then we have our soup
dot find underscore all there's our
brackets
and then if we're looking for each row
in a database
you'll remember your html code we're
looking for
the tag tr so we want to find all tr
and we can take this and let's go ahead
and just take all our rows and do a
print
all rows and about this time you're
going to guess that we're going to get a
huge amount of information
just dumped onto our page and sure
enough we do if you look at this it just
kind of goes on
forever but this is an array each row is
considered an array
so because of that we can do something
simply as putting brackets
and just print the first let's do the
first five rows
so from beginning to five and you can
see here's our first
five rows on here i sometimes like to
just do
let's just do row zero and we see that
row zero is finishers
finishers 191 and just out of curiosity
what's if that's
zero what's row one male okay so we're
starting to see titles going across here
so if we come up here and we do rows we
did what up to 10. let's just take a
look and see what
10 does again and just take a look at
that information that comes across
place bib name gender age city state
chip chip pace gender and so on so it
comes all the way down here
we kind of have an ending right here and
then we have one and then we actually it
looks like we start to have
information so we have our 1 or 1 1191
max randolph that must be the name
male 29 and so on and start seeing how
the information starts getting displayed
going down
so the next thing we want to do with
this i'll go back up here and just edit
the space we're in
so it starts to make a little bit more
sense keep it all together and so we
want to do for
each row in all rows we're looking at
what information are we looking at well
we have
our th up here that's a header our td
down here which looks like the
individual information and we really are
looking for
the actual data so we're looking for td
tags
in the rows and we can do that because
when you remember when it stores the row
it also stores the tags underneath that
so all rows have all the different tags
in it and you can see right here as you
print each one of those out
and so we look at each row we can create
another variable we'll call it row list
and we'll set this equal to in this case
row because we've already pulled all the
rows out of soup so now we want to find
for each row and in there we want to
find our td
and if we go ahead and just print i'm
going to do it if you notice i changed
the indent
so i'm just going to print row list what
this does
is the last value to go into row list
our last row is going to print now and
of course make sure you have an
underscore instead of a period when
you're
typing so row dot find underscore all td
and if we print the last row you can see
i have all the data
coming across here we have our 191 our
1216
zuma ochoa i hope i said that right
female
i believe that's age 40 and so on and
then we can take
our row list and there's a lot of things
we can do with the row list
what we'll do for let's do object or
let's just do
cell in row list and so we're going to
look at each cell because this
is if you look at this they have commas
separated between the different objects
and then we're going to go ahead and
print cell dot text
let's just take a look and see what that
looks like and we can see here for each
row we get 191
there's our 191. there's our 12 16 12 16
our individual who's in the race and so
forth all the way down for those
different settings
and let's go ahead and create a new
variable up here uh we'll call this
all let's just call it data we'll keep
it simple uh so here's our data and then
we have our row
we take our row we break it up into
individual cells
so we'll call this um data row and we'll
set this empty to an empty row
and we're going to take our cells
tab this and we know that each cell
generates a text
and so what we want to do is i want to
take my data row let's just replace that
let's take our data row and let's append
our cell dot text so i'm going to add
the each row is going to be a row of the
different text on here
and then once i create each row i want
my data which is going to be everything
to append
each row and here's our data row and
then if we go ahead and come down here
and let's just print data now if we were
lurking with large data we'd be very
careful about just throwing all our data
on the page
but you can see here we throw the date
on the page and we get finishers 199
male 78 female 113 one and so on and if
you look at this this is the
headers on the file we have finishers uh
male
females just like some general
statistics on the first one and then we
have actually
uh an empty data set and then we have
our data that continues which actually
the
actual information we're looking for so
we have one 1191
max randolph mill 29 washington dc
run time uh one of 78 and so on on here
so we could really quickly get rid of
that number of different ways to do that
one of them is just to do we're going to
set if we do data two on uh we should
get rid of everything but we want to
keep randolph so make sure randolph is
in there oh we lost randolph let's try
one on
there we go there's max randolph on
there uh so we can just simply do redo
our date on here and we can do data
probably want to do it in all rows from
one on but i'm just going to do my data
equals data one on down here and there's
reasons
to split it this way in data science
sometimes you don't want to touch the
original data in case you need it in
case we do need the first row so we'll
put it down here
and maybe we'll just call this titles
titles equals data of zero and so we
could do something here where we print
we'll print up our titles and we'll
print our data in this case instead of
one
on let's go minus two let's look at the
last two rows of data
so here we have our titles and for some
reason just put in
finishers of 191 i was expecting a
little bit more up there and we have our
last couple people and they look like
the data on these looks just fine on
here
turns out this is just some generic
statistics up here so we'll get rid of
titles completely it doesn't really do
us any good but we know that data comes
in here
and we can look at our data and look at
the very end of the data too
the minus two to the end and we can see
it pulls the data in pretty good we
don't have anything too funky in here
we're looking at
it looks pretty clean now you gotta be a
little careful because at some point we
might have to come back here and clean
up the data if we get an error
for running a data analysis we might
find out there's some unusual characters
or something is missed in the data
itself
and you also notice that everything is a
string so when we're bringing it in
we might have to do some conversions to
test it out and convert them to whatever
kind of data format we're working with
so at this time we want to go ahead and
bring in our pandas
and let's go ahead and call this idea
for data frame
we'll set it equal to and if you
remember correctly we imported pandas as
pd and that's standard you'll see that
in most code examples where they call
the import pandas as pd and it is
capital d
capital f for data frame and we're just
going to bring in
our data that's what we called it on
here and let's
uh take this and we'll print now when
you're working with data frames
you're usually talking large amounts of
data and so you almost never want to
print
the whole data frame out we're going to
go ahead and do that anyway just so we
can see what that looks like
and you can see in here brings in our
data frame coming in here and we just
have a mess
of information this is our data let's go
ahead and print
df and see what that looks like in the
data frame and this is nice because it
organizes it into a very easy to read
table
and we have they set the label 0 1 2 3 4
5
6 and so on and then we have each row we
have mel
78 going across
when we get all the way down here we'll
see max randall about number three
and the first thing this does is this
flags me that i brought in a bunch of
information up here that we really
didn't want it's from three on that we
want
and we can clean this up in one of two
ways we can try to clean it up under the
data or we can clean it up under the
data frame depending
on what it is we're trying to do and so
to fix this
i want to go ahead and just change it up
here in the actual data pull in
we don't need that information so i'll
rerun it reload our data from 4 on
and then when i run this we see we have
max randolph is right at the top of the
list like he should be
and we have all the data going down now
with the data frame remember i said we
don't usually print the whole data frame
we'll go ahead and do df.head and this
prints the first five rows
and you can see that we have 13 columns
here's max randall all the way to theo
kinman and i usually also
print df tail and the reason i like to
do these particular two
setups i'm going to change it just to
two rows because you can do that you can
put as many rows as you want
is this good to look at the first part
and the end because those are usually
where you have
extra data brought in uh something's
messed up and you can also see that we
have 190 rows in here
and it comes in with our zuma alicia and
they're both on here on the list so now
we have a nice
data frame columns and rows we can
easily look at it we can see the setup
on here and we can look at the names and
everything
now at some point you might be looking
at these individual
columns and find different information
that needs to be re-edited
if you can you try to do it with the
whole column under pandas
you can up in the upper part of the code
where you went from cell to cell or row
to row
you could look at individual cells maybe
find a marker in that cell that
something specific like remove all
colons or semicolons or something and
there are brackets
there's a lot of options in there but
you'll find that this one actually comes
in pretty clean on here all the way down
and the next thing we really want to do
is we want to look at the headers i
don't know about you but doesn't make
any sense to me when i have
column one i don't know what 1191 is or
1080.
need name kaiser runner i'm guessing
that's column two is names
third one looks like male or female
probably
age but i don't want to guess i want
this to bring in my column so i know
exactly what i'm looking at so how can
we make beautiful soup do that for us
well let's take our column headers
we're going to set that equal to our
soup find underscore all
and then we're going to look for our
headers our th files
and since we're in jupyter lab in this
case jupyter
notebook i can just type out column
headers
if it's the last variable i have listed
it will automatically print it so it's
kind of a shorthand
and we can see right here we have place
i'm guessing that's
bib name gender age city state chip time
chip pace and so on so we have all our
headers right there i shouldn't have to
type them all in
and we'll go ahead and do it before
we'll go ahead and do a header list
equals our empty array and then we can
do
for a column in column headers
and we can take our header list and just
append and what do we want we want the
text from the column so we'll just do
column.text
and then if we come down here and we
print our
header list let's see what that looks
like if we did it right we should get a
nice list of all the different
column headings we want so we have place
bib name and so on
and then pandas just because pandas is
so cool
we can simply do df columns equals
our header from our header list we
simply said df column set to df headers
and then if i print
df.head we'll take a look at that and
we'll see right here it has nicely
placed
our values on here place bib name gender
age and so on so very quickly we've
created this nice data frame
we have the data displayed in nice rows
and columns and easy to read and then
as a data scientist the first thing we
want to know is the info what is
in these columns and rows and headers
and you see right here they all come up
with non-null
object there's a big flag so if i want
to do anything with this these are all
coming through
as strings or an object i usually mean
strings in this case that they're a
string variable and we have
you can quickly read through this 191
entries
date columns total 14 columns there's a
total of 14 columns in the data
and it shows you all the different names
and what type of column they are
and it's probably good also to look at
the shape of the data
df.shape we'll go ahead and just run
that you see it's 191 by 14
14 columns 191 entries this is more like
a
we look at a numpy array 191 by 14 for
the shape
and remember this is a variable so if i
put it on
if it's a last variable or last value
in the set of cells jupiter
automatically prints it out so if you're
in a different ide you want to go ahead
and use the print statement on here
and then one of the things you'd want to
also go through we'll
create a second one df2 equals df dot
drop in a
now the axis is automatically equal to
zero so a lot of times you'll see
something like axes equals zero
comma how equals any axis equals zero is
default
that means we're looking at going down
the rows
you could look at the column going
across let's remove the how any that's
just going to confuse you the axis
is is whether you're going down the
columns or if you're looking at a
row by row by row by row or you could be
looking at it by column by column by
column this would drop
any column and it would drop off the n a
in any column and
how equals and we want any i always
confuse
all in any they both start with a all
means that all of them have to be
non-value where any means that any of
them
can be there to drop it so this would
drop any column
with a null value in it but we want 0
and it'll drop any value with the null
value
and then because 0 is always the default
we'll just leave it out and then it's
curious as to what the
shape is now did we lose anything was
there any null values in our df2 that we
drop from the df and we'll go ahead and
run that
and we see 191 and 14. so we didn't
really drop anything but it's always
good to check there's other ways you can
also do
are there let's see any n a's you can
detect n a's in here
no values infinite values that's another
one you got to watch out for
we're working with data that we're going
to do something with here in a minute so
you got to be a little careful also in
the convergence
are you going to convert something where
people typed in weird characters
to describe the data a certain way so
now we've got to this point where we
have
all our different columns we have our
different data and
at this point maybe you're asking or
maybe the shareholder the company is
asking
hey can we look at the based on
the chip time here's our chip time can
we plot that versus
gender how does gender versus chip time
compare
and so we can do that we can take that
and the first thing we look at is we say
hey well chip time came in
as a string and that's going to be an
issue now there's a number of ways you
can change this
one of them is we could go all the way
back up here where we created the data
and find a way to tag it and say hey
whenever
this cell text maybe instead of
appending this
i notice that anytime there's two colons
in it that's probably a time signature
and let's uh
convert all the time signatures to date
time filled or whatever
a lot of times you don't get that you
don't get that option and that's always
a question in bringing in data whether
you convert the data coming in
at the beginning or do you wait till you
have it open it up and then convert it
when you go to use it
we're going to go ahead and convert it
after we got it into our data frame so
we have our df2 here
we've dropped all of our n a's we
dropped our we have a shape in fact
let's do this
since there's no difference between df
and df2 well we'll just go ahead and use
df2
so let's go ahead and take our df2 and
we want to
take those that specific field and
convert it
into some kind of numerical value we can
use
and let's add another column a lot of
times this is something you want to do
is where you want to go ahead and keep
all the original columns
and just add a new column in there and
this new column is going to be based on
the
if we remember correctly we had chip
time that's what we're going to look at
okay we want chip time
versus gender if we go into our pandas
we find out we have
pandas 2 delta and this is actually time
delta
and then we just want to take our df2
and we're going to use the chip time
column so this is going to say hey let's
look at let's convert
everything in df2 chip time into
a time delta format that's the data type
we're going to put it as and we can go
ahead and just run this
and if we go in here and we do info df2
and we'll keep our we're going to look
at this particular column but we want to
keep it as a data frame
so this is a list of all the columns we
want to look at we'll just do dot info
on
here and run that and we do an info on
that you can see it's now
a time delta 64 nanoseconds
uh well we really don't want nanoseconds
we actually probably want to do it in
minutes uh so let's take a look at that
and let's take this whole thing
tf2 let's just set the df2 we have our
df2
this is a column we're working with here
and we can use the as
type property in pandas and so we can
set this equal to
df2 we'll take our same column in here
and we'll set it as type
time delta seconds so it's still a delta
time here
so if i run this you'll see that it
still comes up as where is it
hopefully it turns it into a float so
we're now at a float 64 so it's the
number of seconds in that delta time
and then finally we want to go ahead and
turn that from seconds to say
minutes and you know there's 60 seconds
in minutes and so now we divide by 60 we
still have a float
we have our info that shows us it's a
float and then we can go ahead and just
do
a print df2 and let's just keep it small
we don't want to look at all our data we
just want to do the head of it and we
run this and you can see right here
where we go to
be the last one here's our chip time in
minutes and a lot of times
just to make life easy for viewing since
we're only looking at
this particular element we can do chip
time in minutes
and now we just see that oops we take
off we'll go ahead and take off our info
done with that and we'll run this and
you can see we have our minutes
16.8 minutes 17.51 minutes and so on
it's a float number now keep in mind
this is 0.8
that's not a 16 minutes and 80 seconds
that they can always throw you if you're
going through so many numbers you forget
so important to remember that and we're
also going to look at the other one
we're looking at is what gender you want
to look at gender
to chip time in minutes and so we can
see here under the head we get
mail mail mail and a number of different
setups and let's
switch this to tail real quick and just
look at the end of it and here we have
female female male female female so we
have two different genders and we have
our chip time in minutes
and if you remember we brought in our
plt if you haven't used the plot library
the matplot library you
have a drawing place you're putting
stuff on so we have our plt we're going
to do a bar graph
and we just want to simply use our df2
gender and df2 chip time in minutes
so that's going to plot the two bars and
to make it pretty we'll go ahead and
give it the x label gender the y label
chip time minutes
and that simply is remember it always
plots x in the plots y
we have our gender our chip time give it
a nice title
uh comparison of average minutes run by
male and female
and if we go ahead and run this with the
correct titles in here and everything
matches
you'll get a nice graph we can see here
the comparison of average minutes run by
male and female here's our chip time in
minutes the men
seem to be slackers in this particular
case and it's actually uh
there's a number of studies that show
that women tend to have
as far as doing cross-country there's a
lot of women who have a longer endurance
than men so it's not too surprising
but we can see here the average chip
time around 70 and for women
over 100 minutes and then another really
cool thing we can do is we can describe
the data
so df2.describe this again is a pandas
function just like info is
we're going to include np number the
numpy number
and if we run that you'll see here comes
up and says chip time in minutes
a count it gives you the average or the
mean standard deviation
the minimum the maximum all the
different descriptive information you're
going to want from your data set on
there
and just because there's all kinds of
fun ways let's do a box plot
to display your information uh we can do
a box plot where the column equals chip
time in minutes
and let's go ahead and run that keep
mistaking my chip time in minutes
you can see it puts out a nice box plot
showing you the information we have our
different values and floaters this is
always interesting because this is a
nice way of seeing where we have these
uh floaters one up here and there's two
up above and of course here
they're a nice spread on the box plot
and we can also uh
modify this a little bit and we can add
in by equals gender
and then we'll give it we'll just give
it a blank title i don't know why we're
giving a blank title uh we'll just add a
y plot
y label on there for runtime and if we
run this you can see here box plot
grouped by gender chip time in minutes
and now we have our female and male
two different areas and you can see how
they vary you have your two different
uh your outlier up here and you can also
see how there's such an overlap
between the two different values so if i
was looking at this i'd be like wow
you know i really could not draw a
conclusive
thing on this saying that women's run
time was more in general because they
overlapped too much that would be one of
the conclusions i'd have to come up with
then here
and then we get to maybe the partners
come in from the company and say hey
we'd like to know the
age versus chip time in minutes that'd
be something worth
knowing on the statistics on this and
the first thought is we can simply plot
it and we can do this we can actually
plot the scatter plot chip time versus
df2 of h there's our xy coordinates but
if you remember from df2 when we did the
info let's go way back up here
we're looking at a data object as far
as our chip time on this and our h now
we converted the chip time but we also
need to convert the
age and if we do it right here we just
plot it and it'll actually let us plot
it it shouldn't it should give us an
error but it does let us plot it you'll
see the ages come up a mess over here
because they're converting it to weird
float numbers and all kinds of things
so we want to do is we want to take our
age and we'll just call this
ah underscore i so we're going to take
our age and we're going to create
another
column for df2 age underscore i
and the i is just going to stand for
integers our own choice of values
there is a number of ways to do this but
we're going to do
pandas 2 merrick is the best way in
pandas and the reason we're doing this
is that numeric creates a float value uh
so right off the bat
we want all our stuff converted it
converts it to the least common
denominator so if they're all integers
already you'll get integers as you can
see from here it's doing some kind of
conversion that converts it to a float
value
the other thing the numeric does is if
there is a null value or they put in
like a blank
line or a dash to represent no
information
it'll convert it to a null so it goes
from like a string to a null versus
just having some kind of made up number
that python somehow created for the
graph we have below
and then we want to add our df2h because
that's what we're converting to numeric
and then we want to coerce it
and there's a couple different options
on this like you can have it where it
just doesn't process it in pandas
but coerce means that if it gets a weird
value that is a null value now
and since we're dealing with errors this
is what happens when you get an error
converting it
we want to coerce it there we go and put
the end bracket on there
and then finally we want to go and round
this off so i'll put brackets around all
the way around it
and this rounds off everything in this
series so we've done here is i've taken
df2h which is a d type object which in
this case is mostly strings with a
couple of blank ones in there and we're
going to convert it to a numeric
which will automatically go to float and
then we're going to take wherever
there's an error wherever it says hey
this doesn't convert
and usually that's a blank screen like i
said i've worked with so many databases
where they someone puts down
none someone types in space sometimes in
a dashed i mean none
and you get this really weird conversion
coming up this covers all of that
in pandas so it's really a nice way of
just coercing it and saying hey if we
don't have a number in there let's make
it a null value and then we're going to
round it off
and then finally let's go ahead and take
our df2 here's our df2 and let's drop
those null values drop in a
and we want how how equals any so that
means if there's any null values
in the data set now you can this might
get you in trouble because you might
have null values in a different column
and so you might lose
data that way at this point we could
also do
like certain parts of like drop just
certain columns with null values there's
all kinds of other options in here what
we're just going to do
how we're going to just drop any and we
want to do it in line equals true
so that means it's going to reassign it
to
df2 so df2 now has a rounded out so it's
rounded to the integer we didn't do any
places
the age and it's going to be age i and
then we've dropped all our null values
that way we're not going to get any
errors when we try to plot a null value
and it also makes sure that
data by deleting out the rows because
that's what this does it automatically
does
axis0 which is your rows axes one is
your column
by doing this it automatically removes
all the rows with null values
so it just cleans out the rolls and then
when we go ahead and plot this
we see we have a nice clean data and we
have age all the way up to 70
so we have our chip time set and then
our age going across
and it makes a nice plot that you can
easily show for display and for the the
um
and you can easily show that to your
shareholders or whatever group you're
working on it makes a really nice and
quick easy display
and with that uh thank you for joining
us today you know for
a quick look at the beautiful soup and
the web scraping tools
in python again thank you for joining us
with simply learn this is
www.simplylearn.com
get certified get ahead richard kerster
have a good day
happy learning and look to see you in
classes if you have any questions feel
free to post them on the bottom of the
youtube
we do go back and look at those
questions and answer them and you can
also visit us at our website
we have a number of different
communities and forums there where you
can ask questions concerning
programming web scraping data science
and just about any kind of certification
program out there you can imagine
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here